the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
if they are used in a crime law
enforcement has no way to trace them
tonight on politics now are ghost guns a
problem how the legislature is taking on
a controversial proposed ban
we got a resident to be annoyed or
scammed by these calls
they are annoying and we get them all
day what the government's doing about
spam calls and scammers
and educating our children we're going
to break down the bill making complex
changes to how we fund education in
[Music]
nevada
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
if you are fully vaccinated you can
start doing the things that you had
stopped
doing because of the pandemic
if you have gotten a coronavirus vaccine
you can start taking off those masks
thank you for joining us on politics now
i'm john langler
this week the centers for disease
control issued new mask
guidelines now anyone who is fully
vaccinated can participate in indoor and
outdoor activities
without a mask and nevada has adopted
these guidelines as well
mask-less president joe biden touted the
updated recommendations
and urged more americans to get the
vaccine
i think it's a great milestone a great
day
it's been made possible by the
extraordinary success
we've had in vaccinating so many
americans get
vaccinated or wear a mask until
you do the cdc says fully vaccinated
americans have to still wear masks when
traveling so we have to wear them on
planes and buses etc
we also have to follow any extra local
guidelines also this week
southern nevada started using the
vaccine for the first time on 12 to 15
year olds
nevada lawmakers have to give 107
million dollars back to taxpayers
this week republicans won a lawsuit
before the state supreme court about the
payroll tax
democrats kept the payroll tax from
expiring during the 2019 legislative
session
but they did not get the two-thirds vote
required by the state constitution for a
tax hike
that money was going to go to education
however this ruling
isn't really going to be a big effect on
the state budget not going to blow a
giant hole in it and that's because
the state now has 586 million more
dollars than expected
and we're going to talk about that a
little bit later on here in the program
in an editorial on the case in the
nevada appeal
senate minority leader james settlemyer
led that lawsuit and says
quote it just shows that they stole
money from people when they didn't have
the authority to do so
a joint statement from majority leader
nicole cannazzaro and assembly speaker
jason fryerson says quote
it is disheartening that nevada families
must pay a price for a lawsuit from
colleagues who are unwilling to stop
playing partisan politics with our
children's education dollars
so now continuing the discussion with
education money plans to change on
nevada funds k-12
schools it's slowly moving forward in
the legislative session
there's a new bill called senate bill
439 it is
dense but it deals with fully
implementing the new
pupil-centered funding plan the i-team's
vanessa murphy breaks it down for us
the bill takes more than 80 different
revenue streams that go to schools and
puts them all into
one giant pot of school money that means
it does away with programs like
zoom schools and victory schools those
are programs that give
extra money to schools with high numbers
of english language learners or students
on free and reduced lunches
instead all the money from the new giant
pot will be given to schools based on
what are called
weights for the students those weights
will be higher for students with special
needs
that are at risk or that are english
language learners
and the school will get more money the
nevada state education association
voiced concerns during the first hearing
this week
saying they want to keep those programs
like zoom and victory schools
so let's talk about gathering up all
that money into one pot
for now governor steve sisilak wants to
only do that with the money from the
state
money from local sources like property
taxes would
not go into that pot for a few years
about
70 percent of the money that goes to
schools now is from
local sources the bill is exempt so
lawmakers have
three weeks to figure out all of that
there has also
not been any new money assigned to
education yet
this session vanessa thank you a
separate bill moves 268 million dollars
from the state's general fund
to schools to help deal with budget
losses during the pandemic
that is senate bill 444 a bill to
abolish the death penalty looks like
it's getting the death penalty top
democrats said this week the bill
cannot pass in carson city governor
steve siselek says he doesn't see a path
forward
senate majority leader nicole cannizzaro
also says an agreement can't be reached
it did pass the assembly along party
lines but it's kind of stalled in the
senate
the bill would have done away with the
death penalty in nevada and convert
current death sentences
into life sentences one of the most
contentious bills this legislative
session has to deal with
gun control a bill that would ban
so-called ghost
guns did pass its senate committee ahead
of friday's deadline
those are guns made with unregistered
home kits
assembly bill 286 already passed the
assembly along party lines it's
sponsored by democratic assemblywoman
sandra yaghiri
she says the lack of regulations makes
it easier for felons and prohibited
people to get those guns
if they are used in a crime law
enforcement has no way to trace them
because they do not have serial numbers
in 2020
federal atf agents raided a nevada-based
company polymer 80
one of the nation's largest
manufacturers of ghost guns
polymer 80 was illegally manufacturing
and distributing firearms
failing to pay taxes shipping guns
across state lines and not conducting
background checks
the problem that you're trying to to fix
the term you guys used was circumventing
the background process
you really believe that if we simply um
require some sort of serial number
on on this and now the these felons are
going to start
not being able to get weapons because
they're they're going to oh geez i'd
love to get one but i can't because i
got to do a background check
that is republican state senator ira
hansen who says the bill all it would do
is punish
law-abiding gun owners there is a
provision in the bill for antique guns
that don't have serial numbers because
they were made before
1938 more than 52
000 opinions have been submitted on this
measure so far
the ghost guns the most commented on
measure uh
most are against it by about six to one
the election bill that makes mail-in
voting permanent as assembly bill 321
it's the fifth most commented on measure
those are about three to one
in favor the bills with the second
through fourth most opinions
didn't make their deadlines a separate
ghost gun ban was in the u.s senate this
week
the justice department says more than 20
thousand guns without a serial number
were recovered by law enforcement over
the past four years
well they split along party lines there
too democrats support legislation to
make it harder to build those weapons
republicans say ghost guns just aren't a
real problem
well they annoy us all and you may get
them on a weekly or maybe even a daily
basis
telemarketing spam robo calls why do we
get so many
and what can we do about them the itunes
vanessa murphy is back with a look at
that issue
please press one now to get connected
with certified technician hey this is
john i'm sorry if i miss you i just
wanted to reach out personally
from those pesky robo calls to
telemarketing calls
all of a sudden recently i got six in
one day
marlo fuller says he's had enough you're
trying to do stuff and
the phone's constantly bothering you the
federal trade commission reports that
more than
46 thousand nevadans filed complaints
about robo calls in 2020.
the state has the sixth highest number
of complaints in the nation per capita
about 35 000 reported typical robocalls
meaning
a human wasn't on the line more than
9000 reported live callers
hello your car warranty is about to
expire
the majority of calls are reported as
imposters think
fraudsters hello this is the irs please
contact
us immediately as you're being audited
warranties and protection plans are next
on the list
followed by offers to reduce debt we
don't want nevada residents
to be annoyed or scammed by these calls
the attorney general's office has a
consumer protection division
michelle newman is a senior deputy
attorney general
anything that would be considered a
deceptive trade practice that's
misleading
um that that's fraudulent that
you know omits a new material
information that consumers
consumers would need to know in january
nevada was part of a federal lawsuit to
take action against a charity fraud
tele-funding operation
the lawsuit states eight defendants
reached 67 million consumers
and collected donations for practically
nonexistent
charitable programs including for
children's
cancer homeless veterans and fire
victims
according to the attorney general's
office the operation
stole about 110 million dollars from
donors including nevadans
while pocketing as much as 90 cents for
every dollar
court records reveal the defendants are
now banned from fundraising and
telemarketing
and they're ordered to sell property and
donate to charity
newman's advice for consumers just hang
up don't dial any numbers
including an option to remove yourself
from the calling list
and register your number on the do not
call registry
as of 2020 the ftc reports more than 2
million phone numbers in nevada are
actively registered on the do not call
list the problem
scammers ignore it i'm on the do not
call list but i still get
these calls about my car warranty and
trying to sell me something
is that allowed no it's not allowed
you can report that unwanted call
as for fuller he has a long list of
phone numbers
he even did some digging and tracked
down one business address to an
empty lot i think
it should be shut down you know
especially if it is a scam
vanessa murphy reporting there and being
distracted by our own staff during her
standups
uh there are apps which can help stop
those calls vanessa mentioned that you
can also
block calls on your cell phone after the
call comes in the do not call registry
though
it doesn't prevent political calls debt
collection or informational calls
surveys and calls for charity are also
allowed
well the state is starting to spend its
extra 586 million dollars
first lawmakers plan to restore cuts to
medicaid
those were made at the beginning of the
pandemic in that program we'll get 125
million dollars this year as you see on
your screen
176 million dollars next year that's 301
million dollars
in the next two years more than eight
hundred thousand nevadans do get
services from medicaid
having trouble recruiting people's
perception of the police
george floyd sheriff joe lombardo
they're telling us all about metro's
hiring problems the budget for the
department
and the tragic case of amari nicholson
welcome back
to politics now
[Music]
the tragic murder of two-year-old amari
nicholson here in the valley has caused
a lot of outpouring in our community the
child's
boyfriend's mother the mother's
boyfriend a bigger partner terrell
rhodes
is charged in the murder as our i-team
reported this week police say that he
has confessed to the crime
after initially claiming the child was
kidnapped
now this week on good day las vegas i
spoke with clark county sheriff joe
lombardo we discussed the amari
nicholson case
we also talked about metro's budget and
trying to hire in this environment
we start with the tragic case that we've
been following for the better part of a
week
the search now and into now the death of
two-year-old amari nicholson
it's a horrible case obviously and i
know there's a lot of investigation
still to be done on this
but just maybe can we talk a little bit
about the challenges of an investigation
like this for detectives
to try and get some resolution
yeah first and foremost i want to send
out my condolences to the family
and and try to get some modicum of
understanding what they're going through
associated with this is a tragic
event and i appreciate you asking the
question john because
you know as you imagine we we're human
beings also and we're when we're dealing
with a situation like this
it charges us emotionally and especially
when we can't get answers
and you know there's a the life of a
two-year-old
involved and i think the most important
aspect of this is for us to get
information in a timely manner
unfortunately we were informed late in
this process
with the missing of the child there was
some assumptions that the child may have
been
with another family member and then you
know we subsequently had to get
heavily engaged because when we realized
there were some problems with the
statements that were being made let's
finally talk about the budget sheriff
last year during the depths of the
pandemic metro had to make a lot of
budget cuts a lot of tough decisions
hiring freezes where do things stand now
as the valley starts to come out of the
pandemic
yeah you're right we did have to make
some significant cuts and
we had some hiring freezes both on the
policing side the corrections side and
the civilian ranks and we even
eliminated some programs
we anticipated the sales tax to be
dire which is a significant number
associated with our budget but
in with the federal stimulus it wasn't
as bad as we predicted
so with that knowledge and the ability
to move forward
and to go back to our sixth academy a
year
program we are increasing hiring
and trying to get back to where we were
previous to the covet pandemic
but that doesn't happen overnight it's
like turning a cruise ship
per se we uh it's going to take us
around 10 to 12 months to get back to
our original numbers
that we experienced before um and
on that note we've got a few seconds
left here we're in the middle of
national police week where we recognize
the work of
the men and women in law enforcement is
it getting harder to
to retain and also just hire folks to
join the force right now
yeah it is um you know we had a we had
not a significant additional number of
people separate from the police
department during the pandemic or last
year on
asus calendar year last year we averaged
right around 170 on the policing side
on an annual basis we had additional 60
people
uh leave last year uh so
and we are having trouble recruiting now
that could be a combination of
uh people's perception of the police um
george floyd post events and then you
know people were in fear of the cover
we were essential workers we had to go
to work on a
daily basis just like normal business
where other people would have the
ability to remain at home and sequester
themselves from the pandemic and
we didn't have that luxury so there was
some fear associated with that
um now we're moving forward the people
are getting inoculated and
and hopefully we can increase those
numbers as we
continue to go forward now we're still
dealing with the perception of the
police
as a as a whole and but here locally
i think our communities wholeheartedly
and hopefully that will be a problem
and of course you can catch our
conversations with sheriff lombardo
every wednesday morning on good day las
vegas
and you can send your questions to him
through us
as well next on politics now is there a
gop
civil war we'll take a look at a change
in republican leadership on capitol hill
that took place
this week plus how long will
unemployment benefits be extended
the arguments for and against entering
those extra payments
you're watching politics now
[Music]
this week the republican party removed
wyoming congresswoman liz chaney from
her leadership position
cheney had been critical of former
president donald trump's claims of
election fraud
we cannot be dragged backward by
the very dangerous lies of a former
president
cheney was the gop conference chair
that's the number three
spot in the house soon after the
decision new york congresswoman elise
stefanik announced her plans to take
cheney's spot
pennsylvania congressman mike kelly
supports the idea
when you're representing the entire
party it becomes a much bigger
responsibility and i think she has the
capability of of course doing that
and subsequently congresswoman stefanik
did replace cheney in a vote
on friday morning republican senators
are calling to end federal unemployment
benefits three months early
and we're talking about the extra 300
dollars per check
many americans are getting right now gop
lawmakers say that money is keeping
people from returning to the workforce
but the white house argues it's the
pandemic that's costing jobs
our washington d.c correspondent kelly
meyer reports
enhanced unemployment benefits are
creating an incentive for people
not to return to work until they expire
florida republican senator marco rubio
says federal
unemployment benefits are keeping
countless workers
off the job success people are lazy
accusing anyone of being lazy it's
because people are logical
instead of working rubio says many in
his state are making close
to or more money from weekly
unemployment benefits
over and over and over again hearing
that from small businesses in various
sectors so not just restaurants and
hotels and hospitality
the group of 10 gop senators want to
phase out federal unemployment benefits
by june
that's three months before they are
currently set to expire
the biden bucks are keeping people from
going back
to work the actual issues at play here
are the pandemic white house press
secretary jen sake says the benefits
aren't hurting the economy
and points to child care as one factor
holding people back
there are millions millions of americans
out there who
through no fault of their own have been
knocked flat on their back this past
year president joe biden has said the
issue is not enough jobs and not enough
that pay well
rubio says that's not the case in
florida what about making sure that
these individuals have
you know a well-paying job to go back to
because of the labor shortage most of
these places are paying more than
they've ever paid before
president biden said this week that
those getting unemployment benefits
must accept suitable employment when
it's offered
reporting in washington i'm kelly meyer
well there's a new associated press poll
that gives president joe biden a 63
favorable rating right now compared to
36
disapproval that 27 point spread is the
widest since he took
office americans though have a much more
sour view of vice president kamala
harris you can see
an economist yougov poll gives her an
unfavorable rating
of 48 41 favorable 57 percent of
independents
view vice president harris negatively
meanwhile up next on politics now
you don't normally think of lawmakers
and tick tock well
one nevadan is using the platform to
good use and we'll talk about that
this week in what to watch friday was
another deadline day at the state
legislature
bills have to make it out of their
committee in the second house so
coming up this week we're going to watch
what to break down some that did
and did not manage to pass we'll talk
about that next week
and we also talked about a lot of
budgets in this show
that has to start wrapping up next week
as well one nevada lawmaker is on tick
tock right now teaching about government
hey tik tok today's wednesday and
today's word of the day is attorney
general and who better to learn about
the word of the day
than the attorney general himself hey
tick tock
i'm the bad attorney general aaron ford
the people's lawyer
and we do a lot of all right that's
assemblywoman selena torres posting tick
tocks little videos about 30 seconds
teaching folks about government she's up
in carson city and this week
it was attorney general aaron ford we
talked about consumer protection and
talked about what his job is right now
she has about 6 500 followers on the
platform
just an early start for assemblywoman
torres on the tick tocks
take a look into that thank you for
watching us here on politicsdown you can
stay up to date with us online
and maybe on tick tock as well we're
back here every saturday thank you for
watching and have a good rest of the
week
[Music]